I wanted to give a lecture about someone
who doesn't get any respect even though
he was the world champion stuff around
here and his name was max obey or you a
and if you're living Holland I don't
want to hear your comments on Twitter or
on YouTube like I could pronounce it I
just don't want to pronounce it right
because we're in America here so it's
max ooh you happy now
his name was spelled e UWE
his first thing wasn't even max it was
masculist
which no american pronounce except me so
you better be happy in Holland right now
he was a Dutch player and he became
world champion basically due to a
drinking problem a drinking problem of
his opponent so one of the most
suspicious world champions ever was
Alexander a Jochen or Alekhine if you're
American and he was an okay player he
was at least expert strength at least
right you agree with that at least and
kappa blanka who beat everybody for
years and years of years he was like oh
boy I'm going to play Alec kind of match
what an easy opponent and so he was
basically you know drinking and staying
out all night and Alec I was preparing
for the match Alec I won the match and
then never would play Kappa blank again
because of aliens shenanigans
we now have rules if you become the
world champion you have to play other
people who are strong to retain your
title okay and Alec ein is like I'm not
playing kappa blanka he'll beat me so
instead he played people that couldn't
possibly beat him or so he thought and
then he played next survey who well
really couldn't beat him but alia can
was occasionally drinking when he was
awake and Mac server want to mention
against him
and unlike Alec I and he gave him a
rematch Alec I decided to win that match
so Mac server was the world chess
champion and he was also two other
things that no world champion has
accomplished or ever will he was the
world and
sure champion which I don't know if that
exists anymore might and he was also the
feed a president he was the president of
chess
okay that was later of course fact I
believe when Bobby Fischer became the
world champion
he received his crown from Mac server
from a previous world champion that
sounds like a good idea okay so I want
to show games that irva one against
famous players and also against his
countryman Dutch players because he was
Dutch
now first game is against Richard Rainey
who was a great player I think I did a
legends on him before ok cool and in
this position although Bishop e5 is a
very strong move black is in check and
black decided to not be in check and
played king a7 actually the best move
here is shocking and rady didn't I
didn't play it
irva played a more shocking move than
the shocking winning move the best move
is actually to attempt to put black and
check on this diagonal because that
would be very close to checkmate and if
you play Bishop d4 check which looks
pretty good black can just take it and
so the best move for white is actually
Bishop to c1 which is a funny retreat
and we're going to play Bishop III check
and the computer says there's no defense
Bishop e3 check is is going to be
checkmate and luckily irva didn't play
that he played much more enterprising
lee and it was also quite good
he played rook to d8 which gives his
rook away the other hand if black
doesn't take this rook rook a8 is
checkmate and black didn't want to get
checkmated so he played b6 now let's
take the rook and see what happens
although he didn't take the rook now
earlier in my discussion i said if the
bishop goes to d4 check the black knight
will take it well guess what the black
knights not there so now Bishop g4 track
Trek is very hard to meet Bishop check
if you play b6 I fork your king and
queen I just did a class on forks and if
you retreat there's a retreat then
Bishop b6 is hard to meet really hard to
meet okay
at Knight b6 check and so forth so he
didn't play nice leg struck he played b6
which is good because now white
sacrificed more rooks played Bishop a 3
again sacrificing his rook if Knight
takes rook rook to e7 and the king and
queen are lined up the bishop is
protecting the rook so he played pawn
takes pawn check and white got out of
check very nice then he played Queen f7
because he wants to get his Queen down
here and checked the white king and
probably that would be pretty good for
black rook ee7 Shak attacking the king
and the Queen so this is the third rook
sacrifice that white is made in four
moves he's going for the record
well you have to take the rook there's
no other legal moves so he took the rook
rook d7 check the King moved to the back
rank because it has two and then the
knight came in with check and the bishop
came in with made and Morphy would be
proud because white used all three of
his pieces to give checkmate they're all
doing a good job and when you attack
your opponent with several pieces you're
much more likely to be successful and
irva was actually quite a good attacking
player as we're going to see later in
his game with Fischer
irva was well known as an opening
steerer Titian he would study the
opening and then play what he studied at
home and in those days we didn't have
the internet and we didn't have
thousands and thousands and thousands of
chess books so basically the magazine
articles and the books were written by
irva he liked to study the opening and
give his opinion
matters some of those opinions weren't
too good and he was a great attacking
player also beating famous Richard rady
who we did a lecture on earlier now the
next two games are against Dutch players
that nobody's heard of except Dutch
people who were alive a hundred years
ago and even then but now this is a game
that he played in to match urban
actually played a lot of matches with
people from his home country to see who
was the best player the Netherlands
since he was the world champion later I
guess it was him okay now in this
position White's King is very suspicious
in the corner here and so our vile
wanted to checkmate the King and he and
after the move rookie two which is the
losing move he played Knight g3 check
Arjen Nigeria good move
now you're forking the King in the rook
now back in 1920 there weren't too many
chess computers right Arjen so sometimes
people made mistakes and we didn't know
about it for years later this position
White has two possible moves pawn takes
Knight and King to g1 those are the only
moves that escaped check and usually
when you have two legal moves you play
the right one and if you even don't know
the rules of chess and you make a move
that's legal you'll be right half the
time unfortunately why didn't do that
here question
well this is a legends class about a
particular legend very specific Fisher
was more crazy than great but he was
good at both he was very talented that
we're going to look at a Fisher game
later as we'll talk about him this class
is only about neck survey the famous
world champion from the 1930s he's a
legend some of the chess players of the
Chess Club here are also legends right
Arjun
legends in their own mind margins like
what okay so no in this class though we
talk about one legend in particular and
we show his greatest games and then
we're like man his opponents weren't too
good yeah now in this position white
should have played King g1 but he took
the night which was a fatal opening of
his King and so black decided that
checkmating his opponent was a good idea
so he made the longest move you could
imagine Queen Age 5
that's a pretty long move white made the
shortest move right his king is in check
so he invited King G 1 pawn takes pawn
now black is threatening checkmate and
if white makes a nothing move let's say
rook a 1 then we go Queen check and
checkmate
the reason it's checkmate is White's own
rook is blocking the escape of his gang
ok so white saw that and he moved his
rook rook takes pawn and then there was
a lot of checks lots of checks lot more
checks lots of checks ok and now black
played the move pawn to g2 and we were
actually talking about the plot in the
previous lecture we were talking about
how pawns can turn into Queens that
would be good because then you'd win so
if what if Black gets that pawn to the
back row that pawn will promote to a
queen black didn't or white I should say
didn't want that to happen so white
played Queen to g4 and if black promotes
to a queen
white we'll just take it so black did
something very sneaky black played the
move Knight to d3 check very good move
it's Czech and the king has nowhere to
go now this was a scholastic tournament
black would probably say checkmate and
white would say okay but these are this
is the former world champion
so they actually can make legal moves
it's amazing so why does not in Czech me
even though why can't move his King
because white can capture the night with
his rook now let's see who's paying the
most attention Black has checkmate in
one move recommended by me if you
checkmate your opponent you win right
Arjen
so who other than Arjen who can find
checkmate in one move I can because I
already saw the game otherwise I'd have
no chance
all right Arjen Bishop f to check me the
Bishop attacks the King and the black
Queen is protecting the bishop and the
King has nowhere to go now actually that
was a good decoy the bishop wants to
jump over the rook but that's not
allowed in the chess rules so we play
check making the rook move away and then
checkmate you don't mess with Mac server
although I don't know he's Dutch so you
can mess up a little all right so that
was a nice victory by the former world
champion
here's another game against a
lesser-known player irva was white and
this is something I tell my students not
to do but he wasn't my student so it's
okay if he doesn't black played the move
c5 c5 is nothing it sneezy at c5
attacking the bishop I tell my students
when somebody attacks your Bishop move
it away but he wasn't my student and I
wasn't alive yet so he has a good excuse
he didn't move his bishop away he
sacrificed his bishop because he did a
counter-attack
sometimes counter-attack works sometimes
they don't white played nine to d5 the
knight is attacking the bishop if the
bishop moves away let's say to g8 then
this pawn is free the pawn wasn't free
last move because the black Bishop was
protecting it so 95 is quite a good move
and they traded bishops black took
White's Bishop and white six black
Bishop now black is in check so he moved
his King and white was very greedy and
took the point on f7 and White's upon a
head the reason black can't capture the
bishop is the white rook is protecting
it now when I play chess and it's moved
20 or so I think it's about move 20 here
I try not to have all my pieces on the
back row that's not good development
okay so black played Knight c7 got his
piece off the back row and as most of
you know the best way to win at chess is
to checkmate your opponent in this game
white knew that but black didn't know
that the black had a good excuse it was
1920 maybe he didn't know what checkmate
was yet and white played rook to f4
which is a very sneaky move because it
looks like it's threatening this pawn
the reason it looks like it's
threatening the pawn is because it's
threatening the pawn but actually white
has a bigger threat and I think black
didn't see the bigger threat he just
played the move Bishop to e6 attacking
this bishop he's like you can't take my
pawn I'm going to take your bishop and
for some reason arjan's hand isn't way
up in the air jumping up and down
screaming yeah that's better
I got it so in this position what move
did white
which led to a to move checkmate
checkmate is good because then you win
also if you were here last week in my
beginners class I showed to move
checkmates I didn't show this one but
here's one and every move is check
making the first move easy to find
because white only has one check right
Bensimon see ya now some of you at home
are very confused not because of the
lecture you were confused before the
lecture you're confused because I'm not
calling on Julian I'm not making fun of
Julian Julian's not screaming out but
there's a good reason Julian is playing
in the World Open in Washington DC and
by the time you watch this video it'll
probably be next year's World Open but
that's not the point I'm not the one on
trial here Ben Simon is but give then
Simon a break he hasn't been paid in two
months okay and the main is a good he
has a good reason he didn't know that
the person who is a supervisor hasn't
worked for two months for the Jets Club
also his supervisor doesn't know that
and what's funny about all those things
I said is they're all true but then
someone's like yeah those are all true
everything he said was true all right
yeah so when your supervisor doesn't
work anymore and you're emailing them it
doesn't doesn't really help okay anyway
Arjun get rid of the bats when we have
the right answer he's like yeah so white
played Knight g6 check notice how it's
check and when you're in check you need
to get out of check and you have to take
the knight and then Rick age four
checkmate
this was a very nice trick it looked
like the rook was attacking the pawn but
of I just wanted to checkmate his
opponent not very nice of him but who
said world champions were nice if you've
met Garry Kasparov you know what I'm
talking about
okay now we'll get to the big boys okay
I'm not saying they were overweight but
okay now most people who play chess
are not on stamps and they're not on the
money right so I have some money on me
now let me see here
no no no all right now on our money
which person on the money is in the
world chess Hall of Fame for his chess
contributions you wait first of all who
told you okay
Benjamin Franklin is on the hundred
dollar bill and he's also in the u.s.
chess Hall of Fame in general strong
chess players aren't on the money he's
not on the money for his chess ability
trust me okay however in this game black
was Paul Kara's probably we should do a
legends on him do we do one yet check
the files Paul Kerr is many consider the
greatest player never to be world
champion many think that now he was
black against Mac cerva many consider
the weakest world champion now to tell
you a funny story because I like stories
when I lived in Belgium before all of
you were born a friend of mine in the
Netherlands was playing Trivial Pursuit
the Dutch version okay so the questions
are like how come nobody knows with the
Netherlands is that's those are the kind
of questions they get okay how come
nobody cares about the Netherlands why
are we such a silly country those are
the main question one of the questions
was who is the greatest chess player
ever from the Netherlands and these guys
were chess players and you would think
since this guy was the world champion
that would be a good answer that was
their answer and the back of the card
said Young's him on so that a lot of
time on films Yan Simha was a good
justify his never world champion okay so
here we have the weakest world champion
versus the strongest never to be world
champion
what what a game okay and they played as
boring as possible yeah okay see it's
the same position what's wrong with them
okay well this is 1939 now black play to
move which I talked about in an earlier
class he pinned the night now the night
can't move okay Bob
Seger wasn't alive yet he didn't know it
was funny how the night moves right Alex
yes can you edit that out because
terrible timing on his part
okay so hurva played III and Paul Kara's
played ninety four which is a really
mean move attacking the knight twice and
I turn the volume off so I can try to
play this move but it won't let me do it
I'm trying but the Queen would then take
the King and again most of you weren't
here for the beginner class some of you
were when I say most of you I think have
if you were if you're playing in real
life you can make lots of illegal moves
especially those guys who are sitting
outside now and if nobody notices that
nobody notices if you're playing on the
internet or on a computer it won't let
you make illegal moves so that's a
little bit different okay so the opening
wasn't very interesting to me it was the
middle game that was interesting okay
and something very interesting happened
by irva and I thought I actually cut off
most of the game but all right
we'll get to the position that I'm
interested in now in the previous games
we looked at before our second and
command showed up over here
irva was checkmating everybody and
sacking all his pieces and playing for
me and that's one of the things he was
known for is a great attacking player
and also known for his opening theory
now this game irva has been winning with
white he has two pawns in the center and
if you count the pawns you'll notice
that white is a pawn ahead white has
seven pawns black has six pawns white is
attacking blacks King White has the
center that's why he was the world
champion
he played rook g3 getting more pieces
into the attack
but Kara's was not a bad player and one
of the things I said earlier most chess
players aren't on the money if you go to
Estonia anybody been to Estonia anyone
been to Estonia on the five crown note
there's a picture of Kara's now he's on
the money yep
okay so he's highly thought of in
Estonia I actually have one of the bills
but I don't know what it is okay
all right King ha9 takes g7 okay irva
likes a play for attack and play for
checkmate and he only did so when he
thought he was right when he was
accurate Queen takes e4 let's see what
happens on rook takes Knight that looks
safe I don't look too safe okay so we
trade rooks and play Queen e7 check now
these pieces are doing a good job
defending or perhaps I'm kidding
perhaps so usually when you have a lot
of pieces attacking you don't have to
give checkmate right away for example I
don't have to give checkmate I could
threaten checkmate if I want but I could
also just take this pawn or I could do
that well I didn't think I could do that
okay that was a that was further back
than we usually go when the thing messes
up I blame my comer why do I blame my
comer she's not here
okay so rook takes Knight is too
dangerous Kara's played Queen takes e4
now he's threatening everything and he
took a pawn okay Knight went back to h5
defending everything and I actually just
wanted to get to one position but I
think I I started too early okay and
then this is the position I wanted where
white plays the move Queen to DA now
occasionally when you're in a chest
database you'll see an error if you
don't know it's an error you will be
confused for the rest of your life
and I got to tell you a story when I
lived in Michigan I got a letter in the
mail and I can actually give a like
about what that is - you kids out there
but I got a letter in the mail and it
said dear mr. Feingold I immediately
threw the letter out because I was
called mister
a year later I got another letter do
your Grand Master final now I finally
read it and it said and it was a check
and caused so then I continued to read
and it said in this game CAD this guy
against this guy kappa blanka said this
is an easy win I leave it for the reader
to decide I've been looking at it for 50
years
and I can't find the win 50 years he's
been looking at it so I said yeah there
is no win cat blank is crazy and he was
like okay great
he thought maybe there's something wrong
with him okay he leaves it to the reader
to find the win that doesn't exist okay
kind of like you showed him so in the
game in question white played Queen to
GA and the commentator put question mark
and then put black resigns so does
anybody know why that happened
yeah he they 9x claim when they put
question market nobody corrected it yeah
you like question mark what a terrible
move now first of all rook takes Queen
is not a good move because rook takes
rook is going to be made but I don't
care about that what I care about is
what is white threatening let's pretend
black played the brilliant a5 going for
a queen what why did white play Queen GA
Arjen where the bathroom is all right
you rug g8 check rook G and that's an
x-ray checkmate okay and after capture
Queen g8 since that checkmate is
threatened yeah there's a lot of
defenses to that if you see one let me
know
black resign in this position after
Queen da but yeah Robin was a brilliant
attacking player and he even beat the
likes of Paul Kara's of course while
this night is far superior to this
Bishop just don't tell my private
students that
as Queen and Bishop is better okay and
well much to the chagrin of the lady who
was here earlier who wanted to talk
about Fisher now we're going to talk
about Fisher but she left so she's going
to miss all the great commentary about
Fisher
okay now Fisher and orbit didn't play
very often for obvious reasons right
right Arjun okay Fisher was playing
chess between 1956 and 1972 and Ervil
was not but okay her beau played a
little bit all right so this was at the
end of herbs career at the beginning of
fishers career they played in 1957 and
to shock you even more this was a match
irva played a lot of matches okay and
you know a prelude of things to kawan
when Ava would crown Fisher world
champion
okay so Hurva was white and this has one
of my favorite moves ever in a chess
game that's why I like to show it also
beating Fisher is pretty good okay they
apply the exchange qgd and Fisher plays
Bishop before the rag goes in which is
very complicated I would play Bishop e7
and lose in calm fashion this should be
force a little more exciting
well this is very popular in Grandmaster
play today h6 Bishop b4 pins the knight
on c3 nothing I want to say worse class
ever but you're sort of average well
this should be b7 is very meek black
wants to play h6g 594 Queen a5 as we saw
in the previous game when irva was white
so the long-term goal attacked the
bishop plane or play the drunken Knight
takes d4 94 attacking c5 Queen a5
putting tremendous pressure black pinned
white pinned black's knight so black
gets to pin white's night and also
there's a big fight for efore so by
pinning the night we get some control of
e4
of course the other common moves are
Bishop e7 and c6 I myself
I've never played Bishop before but I
faced it many times I always play the
most calm boring way possible I don't
want to get any trouble or nothing
in fact if I was white I could even play
Queen c2 transposing to the Queen c2
nimzo-indian a variation where black
plays d5 early
although Queen c2 doesn't do a lot to
develop your Kings side some super
grandmasters will play Queen a4 check
now if they were playing players in this
class they would definitely play Queen a
four-track because some percentage of
you would lose a piece here wonder what
percentage 50 right Arjen one percent
I'm not sure if there is one percent but
less than one percent in this class you
got to come to class four okay so black
has to play 90 c6 defending his Bishop
but now he's blocking is C pawn so some
grandmasters will do this also that
helped your question your fake question
I mean yeah
so you like Bishop before yep okay I
admit if I'm white I'd rather face
Bishop e7 okay so II 386 c5 here comes
Queen a 594 g5 what will earth adieu
Bishop to d3 now remember this game was
played in 1957 so you can't say why
didn't he play Aronian move against the
non because you know that was 2012 yeah
and players now who we analyze these
positions have their computers do it
while they're asleep so players back
here they had to analyze it on their own
and if their conclusions were wrong such
as the famous you know Bob the Nick
Fisher game which are all aware of where
a guy analyzed something for weeks and
his conclusion was wrong he's like oh
yeah I'm winning here I analyzed this
and then Fisher baited womenís worse ok
so in this position
I'm sure it's theory today but ok in
1957 we probably learned from this game
and decided to play better Fischer
played 96 which I'm sure is reasonable
92 and I like to play 92 if I can
instead of Knight f3 when my opponent
plays Bishop to b4 because they're
putting pressure on my knight and now my
knight is not only developed but it's
protecting my knight and if I put my
knight on f3 for example black could pin
both of my Knights and then he has
pressure on my pawn on d4 since by
Knight f3 is pinned so I would prefer to
play 92 if I can and so he did C takes
d4 probably a move that wouldn't be
played today and again white wanted to
keep you know c3 so he took with the
pawn Knight takes d4 is more interesting
this is a little more looks like a
symmetrical pawn structure might be a
draw but white has some advantage here I
think
the bishop on g3 is very strong and I
don't think black wants to trade off his
bishop here he's probably just going to
retreat it later and lose a tempo and
try to claim the night on e2 is passive
pretty good claim ok castles castles
everybody's happy now again let's be
nice to Fisher and I'm never nice to
Fisher must be nice to him anyway
how old was Fisher in 1957 14 at the
oldest could have been 13 although he's
born in March so probably not okay
so Fisher at 14 is playing a former
world champion I mean and he hadn't
become fully crazy yet he was working on
it so probably imagine if you were 14
which I guess Arjun hasn't happened yet
that you're playing a world champion
maybe slightly nervous maybe maybe not
okay this should be six very passive
blocks the e-file Lisa Simpson wouldn't
like this Bishop it's blockaded but
Simpsons we're not 1957 I think the
series started in 58 I remember
correctly yeah Bishop to c2 this is a
typical move of a low-rated player
except when it works that it's a
grandmaster move okay and you know white
wants to play Queen d3 and give them the
old Queen age seven okay seems like a
good idea right okay so this ship goes
back to e 7 because Queen d3 and Bishop
takes f6 and then mate so Knight f4 if
we play Queens e3 now what is black do
to rebuff such a move
making it look quite silly like nobody's
raising their hand so I'll call on you
at home you yeah you know no that's
wrong terrible all right how about
somebody here
how does white get punished for his
indolence playing Queen d3 too early
anyone arch is not even looking too easy
somebody quietly said night before
sounded like Danny whispering nine to be
four and then that mate doesn't work
because we take your queen and then you
got it with your queen because your
Queens attacked I take your bishop
so queen d3 doesn't work queen d3 would
have worked here but black played Bishop
e7 so Fischer was pretty good
okay Knight f4 that'll show that guy
that played Bishop e6 Queen b6 this ship
takes f6 with the idea of queen d3
obviously and now most of us can see the
threat now when white play Knight f4 he
was thinking when I play Queen to g3
I can try to play Queen h7 mate the
normal defense is g6 and now white has a
pleasant choice of taking this or taking
this I would take this because it's more
pleasant okay so Fischer played rook
after DA and said check me I dare you I
double dare you
and then later he sued Quentin Tarantino
among with many other people rook to e1
I'll play queen h7 when I feel like it
first I'm going to make sure your King
can't run away again g6 runs into not
only Knight takes c6 but rook takes c6
yes sir
then you want to play Knight to b4 with
with the Queen make sense I want to play
Knight d5 but I feel like I'm too old to
play that argent could you suggest 95
please now Argent's at 95 let's look at
it
yeah exactly
well if you take my knight I think I'm a
heavy material yeah I think 95 works I
hate to admit it thanks sergeant good
job yeah what did you want to play here
with black okay so you don't like this
firm either yeah it seems like here
black is down a piece and has three
pieces attacked that's probably not a
good sign probably when you're down a
piece you shouldn't have to be visas
attacked when two of them are looks okay
so instead of g6 Rick FDA Irv is in no
hurry
rookie one night to be for attacking the
Queen forcing Queen age 7 he showed him
ok and now this is one of my favorite
moves in chess history which shows you a
kind of life I've led
96 is way too exciting for me
indeed
the greatest food I've ever seen now
okay
so black will play King e7 after queen
h8
unless you don't let him play King nee 7
the true story right somebody suggested
Knight g6 which does prevent King to e7
although the knight is hanging remember
white played Knight f4 earlier so the
knight on f4 and the knight on c3
working together can go to d5 preventing
king e7 followed by me however black has
a thousand pieces defending d5 so if I
take on d5 and take on d5 then you know
you take it on d5 okay so we have to
eliminate one of blacks defenders of d5
so now Margaret knows the answer now I
thought I gave away with that
explanation argent a three very good
that's one of my favorite moves it
attacks the night and when the knight
moves away I'm going to play Knight
takes d5 and check with you don't you
hate when that happens
and on the other hand if you don't move
your night away I'm going to take it so
a three sort of hits him word hurts
Knight takes bishop
obviously Fischer expected Queen takes
Knight and then Knight takes d5 now not
only yeah he's asleeping before yeah
not only is white threatening Queen h8
maid but if somebody in Michigan once
told me White has even better threat
Knight takes Queen
I had a player Michigan saw me taking a
queen was better than me so I'll give
him as kudos here while Knight takes
Queen is annoying and Queen h8 is
annoying unfortunately the bishop on e6
can't take the knight because then the
white rook is stopping the King from
escaping rook takes Knight takes and
even when you're 14 years old you have
to resign here because your queen is
hanging you're kidding
mated and as kids in my kids class would
point out your knight is hanging not
sure why they would point that out but
they would yeah but the fact that Queen
age shadeism 8:00 at night takes Queen
wins a queen
pretty good for irva you know 20 years
after he was world champion when I say
20 more than that so
irva still playing good chess beating a
young Bobby Fischer this game was played
a year after the game of the century
which was what game I thought you'd all
see it in unison game of the century you
witchburn you're so close
he's like 50/50 now that was a better
game but Donald Berg Bobby Fischer 1956
is the famous game where Fischer
sacrificed his Queen Fischer could also
sacrifice his Queen here but he didn't
mean it
so that's that's different when you mean
you know me in it so yeah a3 a brilliant
move by Irving the feed a president and
a great world champion a great chess
player great theoretician underrated
player in my opinion maybe he was the
weakest world champion but if I become
world champion I'll be the weakest that
he will be so famous so he better hope I
don't become world champion he has
nothing to worry about right Arjun
exactly I hope you learned a lot I know
I did and let's let's praise max irva
not only for his great chest but for his
very difficult name to pronounce